[Music]
here the Quran makes the claim that
Jesus foretold that Muhammad upon whom
be peace would be sent after him looking
to the New Testament we find mention of
a similar Prophecy in the Gospel of John
in a series of passages known as the
paraclet sayings in which Jesus said but
very truly I tell you it is for your
good that I am going away unless I go
away the paraclete will not come to you
he will not not speak on his own he will
speak only what he hears and he will
tell you what is yet to come when the
paraclete comes he will testify about me
I will ask the father and he will give
you another paraclete that he may be
with you forever he will teach you all
things and will remind you of everything
I have said to you note the
characteristics of the paraclet who
Jesus proclaimed would be sent after him
it is said that he will not speak on his
own instead speaking only what he hears
in other words the paraclet will not be
someone who talks from his own desires
rather he will be inspired with God's
words this perfectly describes the
revelation of the Quran the very speech
of God dictated to Muhammad via the
angel Gabriel the chapters of the Quran
literally start with the words in the
name of God the coming paraclete is also
said to tell you what is Yet to Come
meaning that he will be given knowledge
of the future both the Quran and
Muhammad's teachings happen to contain
numerous detailed prophecies which have
been proven to be accurate again a
perfect fulfillment of the prophecy
please check out my video series
mindblowing prophecies for many such
examples the coming paraclete is also
said to testify about
Jesus Muhammad affirmed the messiahship
of Jesus his miraculous virgin birth as
well as the second coming when Jesus
will return to the world to defeat the
Antichrist many Christians are unaware
that the Quran mentions Jesus by name
more times than Muhammad himself there
is even an entire chapter of the Quran
that is named after his Blessed Mother
Mary
the coming paraclete is also said to be
someone who will remind us of Jesus's
teachings this actually implies that the
original true teachings of Jesus will
somehow become compromised such as being
forgotten or distorted a good example of
this is Christians today who worship a
trinity which contradicts the strict
monotheism that Jesus taught Islam
corrects Christians in this regard by
reminding them that Jesus never claimed
Divinity for himself but rather preached
and worshiped the same one God As Old
Testament prophets such as Abraham and
Moses in summary we can see that the
paraclete foretold by Jesus was
perfectly fulfilled with the coming of
Muhammad upon whom be peace the New
Testament scholar Robert Price fully
acknowledged that the paraclet was
plausibly a human figure who could be
interpreted in light of Muhammad well
there is some reason to think that Jesus
is
predicting another human being to follow
him to explain his teachings more
because early some early Christians
thought Paul was the the the paraclet uh
others said marcion or monus or
Priscilla or Aquilla or elai or mani and
then finally uh Muslim said Muhammad was
the paraclet I I have to admit there
there is some uh strength to that theory
let's now take a closer look at the
language of the prophecy the word
paraclete that is used to refer to the
individual who will come after Jesus is
a transliteration of the Greek
paracletos this word has posed a great
challenge to New Testament translators
which is why it has traditionally been
interpreted in various ways including
Advocate comforter and
helper however the problem with all such
translations is that none of them
adequately captures the full range of
functions that Jesus attributed to the
paraclet recall from our earlier
analysis that the coming paraclet will
be someone who will perform a rich
variety of functions he will speak the
divinely inspired words of of God he
will prophecy about the future and teach
the world about Jesus this profile of a
multifunctional teacher Prophet has
greatly troubled many New Testament
Scholars who say that it cannot be
reconciled with the meaning of the word
paraclet or paracletos as it is rendered
in the original Greek all the common
translations such as Advocate comforter
and helper fail to adequately satisfy
the profile given by Jesus who spoke of
an individual to come whose functions
are far more active and go far beyond a
mere Advocate comforter or helper to
give a simple analogy it's like saying I
will send a bus driver to perform heart
surgery which is obviously problematic
because a person with the job rooll of
bus driver cannot carry out the medical
function of heart surgery as Professor
Glenn neelon informs us there is a
visible gap between the vital paraclet
and the function John assigns to it the
difficulty reveals itself in the attempt
to translate the term but none of the
translations have met with widespread
approval they all fail to capture
accurately and comprehensively John's
use of the title a title to which he has
given such roles as teacher reminder
witness and
convictor the Bible scholar Raymond
Brown widely considered to be an
authority on johanan New Testament
studies wrote we find that no one
translation of paracletos captures the
complexity of the functions that this
figure has the New Testament scholar
Gary Burge wrote the atmology of
paracletos and its johannine meaning has
proved to be a baffling problem we can
see that none of the common New
Testament translations of the Greek
paracletos such as Advocate comforter
and helper adequately solve this
linguistic challenge that Academia has
dubbed the paraclet problem this is
apparent when One Compares different
Bibles several Bible Publications have
in fact given up on even attempting to
translate the word instead using the
transliteration paraclet which is
meaningless in English the Jerusalem
bible published in
1966 initially translated it as Advocate
only to then later change it to paraclet
in its reviv 1985 Edition it's not only
modern Scholars who have been troubled
by the term even the early church
recognized the problem for example
Jerome a Christian Theologian who is
widely recognized as the most learned of
the Latin church fathers wavered when it
came to translating the term in his
famous commentary on Isaiah Jerome cross
referenced the Gospel of John rendering
paracletos as consolator while in his
work the Latin Vulgate Jerome used
transliterations such as paracletus and
paraclet amazingly it is the Quran that
provides the solution to this linguistic
riddle recall that the Quran claimed
that Jesus referred to the one to come
after him by his personal name Ahmed
let's now take this quranic approach and
apply it to John's gospel by
interpreting paracletos as a a name
rather than a function to see whether it
solves the paraclet problem at hand
according to Greek lexicons the word
paracletos is a compound of the prefix
par and the verbal adjective
cletos the prefix parah can be
understood to mean besides or alongside
and the verbal adjective cletos can be
understood to mean called so it's
understandable why New Testament
interpreter
sometimes translate paracletos in terms
of a legal Advocate as it carries the
meaning of called
alongside however as we have already
seen it is this common meaning that
poses the linguistic issue known as the
paraclet problem now these words also
carry other meanings the preposition
parah is defined as follows in Thea's
Greek English lexicon of the New
Testament above Beyond equivalent to
more than the leel Scott Jones lexicon
likewise defines it as follows past
Beyond over and above in addition to
more than in excess over so par can be
translated in the quantitative sense of
more than or in excess over par retains
these quantitative meanings even when
it's part of a compound word as in the
case of
paracletos as strong exhaustive
concordance confirms in compounds it
retains the same variety of application
Linguistics Professor despa Chilla Marco
po confirms that parah carried this
quantitative meaning of excess at least
as far back as helenistic times citing
the example of the compound word paraga
which means to age
excessively the Greek version of the Old
Testament known as the septu aant
provides a scriptural example of par
being used in a compound word in the
quantitative sense otherwise the Avenger
of blood might pursue him in a rage here
the word translated as rage is the Greek
compound word Paro which carries the
literal meaning of heat to excess let's
now consider alternative meanings for
the second word in paracletos namely
cletos the verb adjective cletos has two
possible etymologies that it can be
derived from the first atmology carries
the meaning to call and the second
atmology carries the meaning to praise
or glorify as the ancient Greek Garian
hesus of Alexandra confirms cletos the
one called by name all the
Glorious Professor Gregory naggi a
specialist in archaic Greek poetry wrote
that the second atmology verbal forms
are usually translated as praise and be
praised the New Testament itself even
uses the related noun form cleos in the
context of Praise Or Glory for example
the first Epistle of Peter says for what
praise glory is it if when you sin and
are buffeted for it you shall take it
patiently given that the New Testament
implo the noun form cleos in the context
of praise and glory it's not
unreasonable to derive the same meaning
praised and glorified using the related
verbal adjective form cletos as it is
found in the Gospel of
John the Jewish philosopher Pho a
contemporary of Jesus also used the
related noun form cleos in the context
of Glory but my scepter shall be the
book of the copy of the law that that
shall be my boast and my incontestable
glory putting all this analysis together
an alternative literal translation of
the paracletos prophecied by Jesus is
praised in excess over or glorified in
excess over this just happens to match
the Arabic word Ahmed with great
precision as it means more praised and
glorified hence both the Gospel of John
and the Quran both paracletos and Ahmed
eloquently convey the point that the
coming person is more praised and
glorified than everyone
else we can see that by adopting the
quranic methodology and interpreting the
Greek word paracletos as a name rather
than as a function such as Advocate
comforter or helper as New Testament
translators typically do the Millennia
old linguistic riddle known as the paret
problem highlighted earlier is elegantly
resolved this suggestion that the word
paraclete might be better treated as a
name should not be too
controversial Bible scholars themselves
have suggested leaving the term
untranslated so that it can serve as a
name as the eminent johannine scholar
John Ashton argues the best solution to
the paraclet problem is to use the
transliteration paraclet since it quote
provides a distinct and recognizable
name for the personage identified in the
farewell
discourse moreover we've already seen
that some Bible versions use the
transliteration paraclet rather than
translating it into English so just as I
am suggesting they're effectively
treating the term as if it's a name
anyway one might be wondering why did
didn't the author of The Gospel of John
just use the word Ahmed why is
paracletos present instead it is
possible that the author came across the
word Ahmed in a Semitic language that
Jesus originally spoke the prophecy in
and decided to translate its meaning
into the Greek equivalent paracletos in
order to make it easier to understand
for its Greek speaking
audience this phenomenon of biblical
authors modifying foreign names is not
at all
uncommon for example the Gospel of John
contains the following account in which
the Apostle Simon is said to have been
given the name keas by Jesus Jesus
looked at him and said you are Simon you
will be called keas which when
translated is Peter the name keas
happens to be Aramaic in origin and has
the meaning of a rock
despite this name being personally
bestowed upon Simon by none other than
Jesus himself we only find a handful of
instances around nine in total of the
original Aramaic name being retained
within the entirety of the New Testament
for the vast majority of cases over 150
instances the New Testament authors
translate the Aramaic name keas to the
Greek Petros which also carries the
related meaning of
estone clearly the New Testament authors
had no issue converting foreign language
names into Greek equivalents based on
similar
meaning with precedents such as this it
is easy to conceive that the author of
John's gospel changed Ahmed from its
original Semitic Language by replacing
it with the Greek equivalent in meaning
paracletos
a common objection that needs to be
covered is that Muhammad cannot be the
paraclete because John's gospel
explicitly defines the paraclet as the
holy spirit in the following prophecy
but the paraclete the Holy Spirit whom
the father will send in my
name there are in fact major issues with
this identification of the paraclet as
the Holy Spirit firstly we've already
seen that Jes Jesus made it a condition
that he must go away so that the
paraclet may be sent by God this is at
odds with the fact that the New
Testament tells us that Jesus was
already filled with the Holy Spirit when
he went into the Wilderness to be tested
by the
devil the New Testament also informs us
that Jesus was casting out Legions of
demons from people by the power of the
Holy
Spirit the New Testament also tells us
that the disciples themselves had
already received the Holy Spirit before
the departure of
Jesus since the Holy Spirit was clearly
already present it stands to reason that
it cannot be the same paraclet who is
said to only appear at a later date
after Jesus
departed there are also historical and
contextual reasons to doubt the
authenticity of the mention of the holy
spirit in the prophecy Professor Gary
Burge informs us that some manuscripts
omit the word holy from this prophecy a
few manuscript variant omit holy While
others read Spirit of Truth some
Scholars have refused to identify the
paraclet as the Holy Spirit the renowned
New Testament scholar Bruce metzka
mentioned that scribes had a habit of
adding the word holy with the word
Spirit the tendency to add holy was both
natural and widespread among Christian
scribes copyists introduced a variety of
modifications The Scholar George
Johnston suggested that scribes added
the word holy because of theological
reasons the insertion may have been done
innocently by a scribe in order to bring
the the text into harmony with other New
Testament passages and with the
Creeds this alternative reading of the
paraclet as a spirit can indeed refer to
a human figure as other passages of the
New Testament associate the mention of
spirit with human prophets now for the
sake of argument even if we take the
reading describing the paraclet as the
Holy Spirit to be legitimate this phrase
can still refer to a man a first century
Jewish apocryphal work known as the
Assumption of Moses referred to Moses as
the holy
spirit in conclusion all the various
interpretations that one can take for
the mention of Holy Spirit in the
paraclet prophecy happen to fit very
well with the prophet Muhammad upon whom
be
peace another objection worth covering
is that interpreting paracletos to be
the name Ahmed creates absurd scenarios
in other passages where the Greek
paracletos also occurs for example John
14: 16 mentions Jesus stating that God
will give you another paraclet which
implies that Jesus is also a paraclet so
if paracletos is the name Ahmed as I
have argued then the implication is that
Jesus is also Ahmed which is
nonsensical in response there is a big
assumption being made in this objection
namely that a single author called John
is responsible for recording all the
paraclet sayings there are in fact good
reasons to believe the Gospel of John
has multiple authors for example the end
of John's gospel informs as this is the
disciple who testifies to these things
and who wrote them down we know that his
testimony is true note the plural
pronoun we indicating that the
commentator here is not a single
individual but rather a group or
community of people as the Bible scholar
Raymond Brown confirms we discussed the
phenomenon of duplicate discourses in
John and here seemingly we are dealing
with another instance of this phenomenon
the same themes and even the same
sayings have been preached gathered and
written down in two different
collections that may stem from different
periods in the history of the johanan
tradition or from different circles in
the johanan
community regarding the paraclet sayings
specifically these demonstrate evidence
of multiple different sources recall
that the paraclet sayings we have
covered in this video occur in three
separate chapters in The Gospel of John
chapters 14 15 and 16 note the following
comments by the disciples in chapter 14
Thomas said to him Lord we don't know
where you are going we can see that
chapter 14 has disciples asking Jesus
questions about where he is going yet
chapter 16 then oddly has Jesus
commenting that no one is asking him
where he is going none of you asks me
where are you going it is clear that the
paraclet sayings in chapter 16
represents a stream of tradition that is
different to that of the paraclet saying
from chapter 14 as they contradict one
another this conclusion that the
paraclet sayings are composed from
multiple sources is widely accepted in
Academia as the textual scholar Bart Man
confirms reader have devised different
ways of explaining these kinds of
literary problems over the years but
perhaps it is simplest to say that they
have resulted from the author's decision
to weave different written sources into
his narrative there is a repetition
between chapters 14 and 16 because they
were in fact two accounts of the same
event joined together we can see that
the various chapters containing the
paraclet sayings were not taken from a
single Source but rather are multiple
sources joined together hence it is not
inconceivable that these different
sources applied the term paracletos in
different ways as the Theologian Kenneth
gyon confirms if it seems improbable
that different meanings of paracletos
should be present in such close
proximity it may be replied that John 14
and John 15-6 are now widely regarded as
variant forms of a final discourse
presumably composed to suit different
situations another possibility to
consider is that the authors of the
sources that call Jesus a paraclet were
uncomfortable with the notion that there
could be someone coming after Jesus who
will be more praised and glorified than
him in other words Jesus was transformed
into another paraclet for theological
reasons one chronological sequence that
explains how such a situation might
arise is as follows first the author of
the earliest paraclet saying Source
changed Ahmed from its original Semitic
Language by replacing it with the Greek
equivalent in meaning paracletos as we
have already
discussed second the later authors of
other texts which explicitly refer refer
to Jesus as a paraclet were aware of
this earlier paraclet saying Source when
composing their writings they would have
also been aware of the multiple meanings
of paracletos one of which is praised in
excess over or glorified in excess over
they could have been disturbed by the
notion that someone might be more
praised and glorified than Jesus hence
for theological reasons they decided to
call Jesus a paraclet as well in order
to elevate his status to be on an equal
footing with the prophecied
paraclete this scenario is not so
far-fetched considering that we have
already seen evidence that scribes
inserted the word holy into the paraclet
sayings in order to transform the
paraclete from a human figure to the
Holy Spirit moreover there are many
examples throughout the four gospel Els
in which their authors manipulated
accounts about Jesus in order to elevate
his status some examples include the
incident of the woman in the crowd
compare Mark 5 with Matthew 9 the
incident on the boat in the storm
compare Mark 4 with Luke 8 the incident
of the man questioning Jesus compare
Mark 10 with Mark 19 and the incident of
Jesus on the cross
compare Mark 15 with Luke 23 for more
details of all these examples please
refer to my video were the gospel
authors divinely
inspired so in summary Prophet Muhammad
upon whom be peace could well have been
the original and only paraclet whereas
Jesus was transformed into one for
theological reasons
for more information on biblical
prophecies about the coming of Muhammad
upon whom be peace please download your
free copy of the book Abraham fulfilled
at the link below